This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. When you imagine a powerful person, what comes to mind? Gaffney, we had our own brand of diplomacy. Shake with your right hand, but hold a rock in your left. Perhaps you don't picture someone as evil as Frank Underwood from House of Cards. But you also probably don't think of someone very nice. We don't normally associate power with qualities like compassion and kindness. But the psychologist Docker-Cantner at UC Berkeley says, maybe we should.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。当你想象一个有权势的人时，你会想到什么？加夫尼，我们有自己的一套外交风格。右手握手，左手藏一块石头。也许你想象的并不是像《纸牌屋》里的弗兰克·安德伍德那样邪恶的人。但你可能也不会想到一个非常善良的人。我们通常不会把权力与同情心和仁慈等品质联系起来。但加州大学伯克利分校的心理学家达克·凯尔特纳说，也许我们应该这样做。
What the science is finding is that kids at school, kids in summer camps, people in colleges, people in organizations, if they are emotionally intelligent and really focus on others and even practice generosity, they rise in social power. Docker studies power dynamics and he's found something that might seem counterintuitive. If you think of power as all about Machu valiance scheming, The people would display altruism, kindness, social intelligence. Docker finds that these are the people who gain power and respect from their peers. But there's a catch.
科学研究发现，无论是学校里的孩子、夏令营的孩子、大学里的年轻人，还是组织中的人们，如果他们情商高、真正关注他人甚至实践慷慨，他们就会提升自己的社会影响力。达克研究权力动态，他发现了一些可能违背直觉的现象。如果你认为权力全在于马基雅维利式的阴谋诡计，但表现出利他主义、善良和社会智能的人，达克发现，正是这些人才会从同龄人那里获得权力和尊重。但这里有个问题。
Once these people become powerful, power tends to undermine the very qualities that help them get there in the first place. There's something about the seductions of power that makes you lose sight of ethics and other people's interests. Docker Calthner is the author of the new book, The Power Paradox, How We Gain and Lose Influence. We think his ideas are especially relevant right now when so many people are vying for power in this election season. Dacker, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's great to be with you, Shankar.
一旦这些人变得有权有势，权力往往会侵蚀那些最初帮助他们获得权力的品质。权力的诱惑似乎有一种魔力，让你忽视伦理道德以及他人的利益。达克·凯尔特纳是新书《权力悖论：我们如何获得与失去影响力》的作者。我们认为他的观点在当今这个选举季有这么多人争夺权力的时刻尤为重要。达克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴能和你在一起，尚卡尔。
I'm fascinated by the research that you cite in the book, Dacker, that suggests that power shapes nearly all of our relationships. If you put a bunch of 13-year-old kids in a room, you say that power dynamics quickly emerge, and you make the case that kids who are kinder and more empathetic are the ones who quickly assume the mantle of power in the group. So you're right on both counts, Shankar. First of all, one of the things that we've learned in the science of power is that really power dynamics, who's influencing whom, shape every relationship from parent child dynamics
达克，我对你在书中引用的研究很感兴趣，这些研究表明权力几乎塑造了我们所有的关系。如果你把一群13岁的孩子关在一个房间里，你说权力动态会迅速显现，你还指出，更善良、更有同理心的孩子往往会迅速在群体中占据权力的位置。所以你的两个看法都是对的，尚卡尔。首先，我们在权力科学中了解到的事情之一是，权力动态，即谁在影响谁，塑造了从亲子关系
to dynamics in the US Senate. And then, you know, what we've discovered over the past 20 years is probably a little bit counterintuitive and it challenges older ideas about power, more Machiavellian ideas. And what the science is finding is that kids at school, kids in summer camps, people in colleges, people in organizations, if they are emotionally intelligent and really focus on others and even practice generosity, they rise in social power. I have to say it's like here that I have some skepticism and this might be because you attended nicer schools than I did, but my experience of middle school felt more emotionally like
到美国参议院动态的每一种关系。然后，你知道的，我们在过去20年里发现的可能有点反直觉，它挑战了关于权力的陈旧观念，即更倾向于马基雅维利式的观念。科学研究发现，无论是学校里的孩子、夏令营的孩子、大学里的年轻人，还是组织中的人们，如果他们情商高、真正关注他人甚至实践慷慨，他们就会提升自己的社会影响力。我不得不说，正是在这里我产生了一些怀疑，这可能是因为你读的学校比我好，但我的中学体验在情感上感觉更像是
the Hunger Games that kids who were stronger and louder and mean are often got that way. I mean, is my experience an aberration? Well, I don't know where you went to school, but it tends to be an aberration. You know, so what these studies do is they take a group of seventh graders. You find out who has respect in a steam at the start of the year. You study what their social behaviors are, their social strategies, and then you track how they do in the hierarchy of that seventh grade class to use your example. And, you know, what you find is, yes, the bullies and the Machiavellians, the sociopaths, they get a little bit of attention early. But over the long haul, and this is true
《饥饿游戏》，那些更强壮、声音更大、更刻薄的孩子往往就是这样掌权的。我的经历难道是一个特例吗？嗯，我不知道你是在哪所学校上学的，但这种情况往往是一个特例。你知道的，这些研究的做法是，他们找来一群七年级学生。你会在学年初找出谁最受尊重和敬仰。你研究他们的社会行为和社交策略，然后追踪他们在七年级这个阶层（借用你的例子）的等级制度中的表现。你知道的，你发现的是，是的，恶霸和马基雅维利主义者、反社会者，他们早期会得到一些关注。但从长远来看，这在
in other contexts, they don't have as much power as they would like to. And instead, what studies find now numbering in the dozens, it's really the connecting kid, the empathetic kid, the kid who's really open and curious, who really rises in the esteem and the ranks of the class. I'm wondering if this really comes down to thinking about power in two different ways. The power that I'm hearing you talk about is really reputational power. I think of doctors without borders, for example, it's having reputational power. They don't cut my paycheck and they can't fire me, but I pay attention to what they say because I respect them as an organization.
其他语境中也是如此，他们并没有获得他们想要的那么多权力。相反，现在数十项研究发现，真正能够建立联系的孩子、富有同理心的孩子、真正开放和好奇的孩子，才是在班级声誉和阶层中真正崛起的人。我想知道，这是否真的归结为以两种不同的方式看待权力。我听你谈论的权力实际上是声誉权力。例如，我想到了无国界医生组织，它拥有声誉权力。他们不给我发工资，也不能解雇我，但我关注他们说的话，因为我作为一个组织尊重他们。
On the other hand, when you have coercive power, people who can punish you or people who can take away your life or your freedom, it feels like maybe is it possible that those two different, there are two different paths to power for those two different kinds of power? Absolutely, and that's a wonderful observation, and so one of the things that the science of power is done, which I report on in the power paradox, is to take a step back and think, what do we really mean by power? We intuitively define it as money, but a lot of things happen in the world
另一方面，当你拥有强制性权力，即那些可以惩罚你、或者可以剥夺你的生命或自由的人时，感觉也许——有没有可能这两种不同的权力，存在着通往权力的两条不同路径？绝对是的，这是一个极好的观察，因此权力科学所做的事情之一，我在《权力悖论》中也有报道，那就是退一步思考：我们所说的权力到底是什么意思？我们凭直觉将它定义为金钱，但世界上发生了很多事情
that are independent of capital. We might think of it historically as military might, but you can easily come up with counter examples where a man's military might actually produces weakness. And so we have to kind of problematize it and what the field has done is thought about one strategy to power that works in certain contexts is a kind of a coercive top-down Machiavellian strategy. Another kind is a more socially intelligent strategy that involves some of these things we've been talking about.
是独立于资本之外的。我们在历史上可能会认为它是军事力量，但你很容易举出反例，说明一个国家的军事力量实际上会产生软弱。因此，我们必须对它进行追问，而这个领域所做的是思考：在某些情况下发挥作用的一种权力策略是一种强制性的、自上而下的马基雅维利式策略。另一种则更具社会智能，涉及我们一直在讨论的一些要素。
And you know what's really interesting, Shankar, and one of the things that inspired me to write this book is a lot of data that have been summarized by people like Alice Egley finding that our conception of power is moving from coercive strategies to more collaborative strategies. So it's one of the reasons I wrote this book. So when you describe this kind of power that is more reputational, by that account you would say, you know, the United States's power in the world is not just a reflection of the strength of its military and the size of its armed forces. It's really about the power of its ideas and its ability to do well in the world. Is that the argument you're making that this kind of soft power in some ways is more important than the hard power that we've come to associate with power? Well this is one of the ideas that really spurred the science of power in our lab and other labs for the past 20 years, which is that if you think about the influence the US has
你知道最有趣的是什么吗，尚卡尔，激发我写这本书的原因之一是爱丽丝·埃格利（Alice Eagly）等人总结的大量数据，他们发现我们对权力的理解正在从强制性策略转向更多合作性策略。所以这也是我写这本书的原因之一。因此，当你描述这种更具声誉的权力时，按这种说法你会说，美国在世界上的权力不仅仅是其军事力量和军队规模的体现。它实际上是其思想的力量以及它在世界上做好事的能力的体现。这就是你的论点吗？即这种软实力在某种程度上比我们习惯于与权力联系在一起的硬实力更重要？嗯，这是过去20年里真正激发我们实验室和其他实验室进行权力科学研究的想法之一，也就是说，如果你想想美国对
on the average world citizen, part of it is through the flow of capital and economics and part of it is having this expansive military, but a bigger component or dimension to our power is how do we shape the thinking of people around the world? How do we shape the emotions of people around the world? Are there what they deem to be fair or right? And that comes through books, it comes through forms of art, it comes through journalism. And I think, you know, I took that thinking of soft power, if you will, which is in some ways is harder, and really
普通世界公民的影响，一部分是通过资本和经济流动实现的，一部分是通过拥有庞大的军队实现的，但我们权力的一个更大组成部分或维度是，我们如何塑造世界各地人们的思想？我们如何塑造世界各地人们的情感？什么是他们认为公平或正确的事情？这是通过书籍、艺术形式、新闻业传播的。而且我认为，你知道的，我把这种软实力的思想（如果你愿意这样称呼的话，它在某些方面更难把握）
extended it to the personal realm, which is that as a parent, yeah, I have economic control over my kids. I have, I'm bigger than they are. But really, I also influenced them through ideas, through preferences that I enable, through the context that I put them in. So power is much more than economic or military might. It's really how we influence the states of other people.
延伸到了个人领域，也就是说，作为父母，是的，我有对孩子的经济控制权。我有，我比他们体型更大。但实际上，我也通过思想、通过我允许的偏好、通过我把他们置于的环境来影响他们。因此，权力远不止于经济或军事力量。它实际上是我们如何影响其他人的状态。
You're talking the book about the story of Abraham Lincoln and psych is rise to power as a classic example of what you're talking about, the skills that you're talking about. Yeah. One of the things I did, or you know, in the three years of writing this book, and really, while I've been doing the science of power, is just to read broadly on the biographies of great leaders, the historical accounts of important social change. And you know, what I encountered is time and time again that there are these examples, very compelling examples of great leaders who lead through advancing the interests of other people. I mean Abraham Lincoln was such a compelling example, and I love this observation about
你在书中谈到了亚伯拉罕·林肯的故事以及他崛起的心理过程，这是你所讨论的内容的经典例子，也就是你所讨论的那些技能。是的。我所做的事情之一，或者说在我写这本书的三年里，以及在我进行权力科学研究的过程中，就是广泛阅读伟大领袖的传记、重要社会变革的历史记述。你知道，我一次又一次遇到的是，有这样的例子，非常引人注目的伟大领袖的例子，他们通过推进其他人的利益来进行领导。我的意思是亚伯拉罕·林肯就是一个如此引人注目的例子，我非常喜欢关于
him of Thurlow Weed, who was a journalist at the time and a close student of the politics of Lincoln's era. And he's like, what is it about Lincoln that accounts for his really unpredictable rise in power? He's a poor guy, awkward, didn't have all the advantages that often give you power. And he said, Thurloweed said, you know, Lincoln sees and hears everybody who comes to him. He just engages in the interests of others. And then when I read that, and then I heard about the science,
他的这段观察，瑟洛·韦德（Thurlow Weed）是一位当时的记者，也是林肯时代政治的密切研究者。他说，林肯身上有什么特质促成了他那不可预测的权力崛起？他是个穷小子，笨拙，没有通常能给你带来权力的种种优势。瑟洛·韦德说，你知道，林肯会见和倾听每一个来找他的人。他只是全心投入到他人的利益中。然后当我读到这个，然后又听到了关于科学的研究，
for example, of Stiffon Cote, showing it's really these emotionally intelligent managers in workplaces that rise in the ranks and build strong teams. I saw this nice convergence of evidence. strong teams, I saw this nice convergence of evidence. When we come back, I'm going to ask Dacquer about several experiments he's conducted that show that even as kindness and empathy can give rise to power, having power can undermine kindness and empathy. Stay with us.
例如斯蒂芬·科特（Stiffon Cote）的研究表明，正是职场中这些情商高的管理者在层级中脱颖而出并建立起强大的团队。我看到了这种证据的奇妙交汇。建立强大的团队，我看到了这种证据的奇妙交汇。当我们回来时，我将询问达克关于他进行的几项实验，这些实验表明，尽管善良和同理心可以催生权力，但拥有权力却会侵蚀善良和同理心。请继续收听。
Support for NPR and the following message come from care.com, a great place to find in Annie. Stay with us. to an anti-tax preparation. Care.com home pay makes it easy to set yourself up for success. Learn more at myhomepay.com. Support also comes from Talkspace. Talkspace provides an affordable, confidential and convenient way to access unlimited messaging to a dedicated and licensed therapist for a low-weekly cost. With Talkspace, you can text, audio message, or video message your therapist as many times as you want.
NPR及其以下赞助信息来自care.com，这是寻找保姆的绝佳平台。请继续收听。寻找税务筹备服务。Care.com home pay让您轻松为成功做好准备。了解更多信息请访问 myhomepay.com。赞助还来自 Talkspace。Talkspace 提供了一种经济实惠、保密且便捷的方式，让您只需支付较低的周费，即可通过无限量信息联系专属的持证治疗师。通过 Talkspace，您可以随心所欲地给您的治疗师发短信、发送音频或视频消息。
Visit Talkspace.com slash brain for a special 20% discount off your first month. Or download the Talkspace app on the Apple or Android app store and use the coupon code brain. Talkspace, therapy for how we live today. Hi there, I'm Maggie Penman, I'm one of the producers of Hidden Brain. Encouraging you to download the NPR1 app. As summer winds down, it's a great way to find new shows and stories for those lovely last-road trips to the beach, or if vacation is over for you, maybe you could download it
访问 Talkspace.com/brain，您的第一个月即可享受专属的 20% 折扣。或者在 Apple 或 Android 应用商店下载 Talkspace 应用并使用优惠券代码 brain。Talkspace，适应我们现代生活方式的心理治疗。大家好，我是麦琪·彭曼（Maggie Penman），我是《隐藏的大脑》的制作人之一。鼓励大家下载 NPR1 应用。随着夏天的临近尾声，对于那些前往海滩的可爱最后公路旅行，或者如果你的假期已经结束，这都是寻找新节目和新故事的好方法，也许你可以在
before your morning commute. Basically, you should just download it. It's in your App Store, NPR-ONE. Dacker, you've done a lot of work looking not just at the forces that give rise to power, these forces of empathy and generosity and kindness, but also what power does to those forces in turn, that when people acquire power, it seems to change their ability to be empathetic, to be kind. Talk about that.
早晨通勤前下载它。基本上，你真应该下载它。它就在你的应用商店里，搜索 NPR-ONE。达克，你做了大量的工作，不仅研究了催生权力的力量——这些同理心、慷慨和善良的力量，还研究了权力反过来对这些力量的影响，即当人们获得权力时，它似乎改变了他们保持同理心和善良的能力。请谈谈这一点。
Well, this was some of the more dramatic work that we engaged in, that's now been replicated in a lot of different places. And that's why I call the Book the Power Paradox, which is, if you look at this social science of power, we get power through the pro-social tendencies that we are in doubt with. But then once we feel powerful, or we come from a background of privilege and feeling above others, we lose those tendencies. So let me give you an example.
嗯，这是我们开展的一些更具戏剧性的工作，现在已经在许多不同的地方得到了复制。这也是为什么我把这本书命名为《权力悖论》，即如果你看看权力的社会科学，我们会通过我们天生具备的亲社会倾向来获得权力。但是一旦我们感到强大，或者我们来自特权背景并感觉高人一等，我们就会失去这些倾向。让我给你举个例子。
There are a lot of studies that show that empathetic practices get you power. So one of my favorites is work by William College showing, you know, you give teams these complex problems to solve. It's really the more empathetic individuals that make their team stronger and perform better, right? They're listening well, they're asking good questions, they're paying attention to other people. So, empathy makes the team and the individual stronger.
有很多研究表明，同理心实践能为你带来权力。我最喜欢的研究之一是威廉·柯利（William College）的工作，他表明，你给团队这些复杂的解题任务，正是那些更富同理心的个人让他们的团队更强大、表现更好。他们善于倾听，善于提出好问题，关注其他人。因此，同理心让团队和个人变得更强大。
And then what we started to show in our lab is once we feel powerful, we lose our capacity to empathize and to know what others are thinking, really is diminished. So in one study, really simple, we get bring people to the lab, we have them engage in this exercise where they compare themselves to the sort of the real poor people of society and it makes them feel powerful.
然后我们开始在实验室里展示的是，一旦我们感到强大，我们共情和了解他人想法的能力就会丧失，确实会减弱。因此在一项研究中，非常简单，我们把人带到实验室，让他们参与这样一项练习：将自己与社会上真正的穷人进行比较，这让他们感到自己很有权势。
Or they compare themselves to the kind of the elite of society and they feel as a result of that comparison less power. And then we just present them some photos of people expressing different emotions with subtle muscle movements around the eyes, like concentration or flirtatious or decisive. And what we find is when you feel powerful, you lose your ability to read emotion in people's facial expressions. Why would that happen? Well, I mean, there are a couple of deep reasons.
或者他们把自己和社会的精英阶层进行比较，结果这种比较让他们觉得自己权力较小。然后我们向他们展示一些人们表达不同情绪的照片，这些照片伴随着眼睛周围微妙的肌肉运动，比如专注、调情或果断。我们发现，当你感到有权势时，你就会失去解读人们面部表情中情绪的能力。为什么会这样？嗯，我的意思是，有几个深层原因。
One is, you know, and this is just striking research by Keely Mescatel and Sukvindu Obi, which is that, you know, Shanko, if I feel powerful, the studies show, I just feel less interested in other people, less invested in them, and as a result, the empathy networks in the brain are actually quieted. They're less active, so Keely Muscatel brought people to the lab, She had them sort of
一个是，你知道的，凯利·穆斯卡特尔（Keely Muscatel）和苏文杜·奥比（Sukvindu Obi）进行了引人注目的研究，那就是，尚卡尔，如果我感到有权势，研究表明，我只是对其他人感到兴趣索然，对他们的投入减少，因此，大脑中的同理心网络实际上变得安静了。它们的活跃度降低了，所以凯利·穆斯卡特尔把人们带到实验室，她让他们去
think about another student's daily life. And if you come from a position of privilege and power, the classic empathy networks in the frontal lobes of your brain are not even active when you're thinking about another student. So, this is a very deep effect of what power does to our empathic capacities. So what you're saying in some ways is that we are empathetic to others in part because that's useful to us. We lack power in many situations and being empathetic and being aware of others allows us to navigate
思考另一个学生的日常生活。如果你来自特权和权力的地位，当你思考另一个学生时，你大脑额叶中经典的同理心网络甚至都不会被激活。因此，这是权力对我们的同理心能力产生的一种非常深远的影响。所以你某种程度上是在说，我们对他人产生同理心，部分原因是这对我们有用。我们在许多情况下缺乏权力，而富有同理心并意识到他人存在，能让我们有效地
our social worlds effectively. But when we perceive ourselves having power and privilege, in some ways we don't need to depend as much as we do on others, we don't need to depend as much as we do on others. We don't need to reach out to others. And so those networks shut down. Yeah. No, really well put because if you think about, for example, somebody who's poor and doesn't
驾驭我们的社交世界。但是，当我们认为自己拥有权力 and 特权时，在某些情况下，我们不需要像以前那样依赖他人，我们不需要像以前那样依赖他人。我们不需要向他人求助。于是这些网络就关闭了。是的。不，说得真的很好，因为如果你想想，例如，某个贫穷且没有
have a lot of resources, they're dependent on other people to get to work, to do a little bit of, you know, ad hoc child care or what have you. So you're dependent on others and out of that state of mutual dependence, you really with vigilance attend to other people and are aware of what they're doing. And that produces these empathy benefits coming out of less power. And then the compliment, you lose that empathy when you feel less dependent on others and powerful. So one of the paradoxes of this is something that you and others have identified, which is to look at the generosity of people who are rich and poor, and you find some really surprising things. Yeah.
很多资源的人，他们依赖其他人去上班，去做一点，你知道的，临时的儿童看护或诸如此类的事情。所以你依赖他人，在这种相互依赖的状态下，你会高度警惕地关注他人，并意识到他们在做什么。这产生了源自权力较小的同理心收益。相对应地，当你觉得不那么依赖他人、感觉自己很有权势时，你就会失去那种同理心。所以这里的悖论之一是你和其他人已经指出的事情，那就是审视富人和穷人的慷慨程度，你会发现一些非常惊人的事情。是的。
So, again, what studies are finding, and again, this is part of the power paradox, which is that there is this really interesting literature called competitive altruism, and if you take the average person in a social network and they practice generosity and they share resources or they encourage others through those acts of generosity, they rise in power. People trust them, they esteem them. You even see this in hunter-gatherer societies
所以，再次说明，研究发现——这也是权力悖论的一部分——存在这样一篇非常有趣的文献，称为竞争性利他主义。如果你把社交网络中的普通人抽样出来，如果他们实践慷慨并分享资源，或者通过这些慷慨行为鼓励他人，他们的权力就会上升。人们信任他们，尊重他们。你甚至可以在狩猎采集社会中看到这一点，
where it's really the individual who shares the most food in the hunter-gatherer societies who rises in the ranks. And yet, you know, what we started to find with Paul Piff and other colleagues is, once I feel powerful, I proved to be less generous. So in one study, we brought people to lab who varied in terms of their social class and family wealth. We just gave them a very simple opportunity to share resources with a stranger. And we found it was really the poor who shared more and higher power people, more privileged, people shared less.
在狩猎采集社会中，真正提升到社会高阶的恰恰是那些分享最多食物的个人。然而，你知道，我们开始与保罗·皮夫（Paul Piff）和其他同事一起发现的是，一旦我感到自己有权势，我就会表现得不那么慷慨。因此，在一项研究中，我们将社会阶层和家庭财富各不相同的参与者带到实验室。我们只是给他们一个非常简单的机会，与陌生人分享资源。我们发现，实际上是穷人分享得更多，而权力更高、更有特权的人分享得更少。
Now, obviously, people who are millionaires and billionaires, they might be philanthropic and they might give larger amounts of money. But what you're really saying is it's a proportion of your wealth for a millionaire to give a thousand dollars is not the same thing as somebody at the poverty line who's giving fifty. Yeah, we always have to be careful about how we interpret these results. And these are just, you know, proportions of sharing and not absolute amounts and you absolutely right.
现在，很显然，百万富翁和亿万富翁可能会进行慈善捐赠，他们可能会捐出更多的钱。但你真正想说的是，这关乎财富的比例——对于一个百万富翁来说，捐出一千美元与处于贫困线的人捐出五十美元是完全不同的概念。是的，我们在解读这些结果时总是必须小心谨慎。这些仅仅是，你知道的，分享的比例而不是绝对金额，你的看法完全正确。
But you even get this experimentally. So, you know, in one of our early studies in power, we were interested in does experimentally produce power lead to kind of the hoarding of resources which we've been talking about. We brought groups of three people to the lab. We randomly signed one individual to the position of power. And then by design, they went through this experiment and was kind of boring and writing policies for the university. And we brought in halfway through the study, this plate of five chocolate chip cookies. Every member of the group, three people all together, took a cookie, and so we asked who
但你甚至可以通过实验得到这个结果。所以，你知道的，在我们早期的权力研究之一中，我们感兴趣的是：实验中产生的权力是否会导致我们一直在讨论的资源囤积？我们将三个人一组带到实验室。我们随机指派其中一个人担任权力职位。然后按照设计，他们经历了这个实验，这有点无聊，比如为大学撰写政策。在研究进行到一半时，我们拿进来一盘五个巧克力豆曲奇饼干。组里的每个成员，总共三个人，都拿了一块曲奇，所以我们问是谁
took that fourth cookie, and it was our high-power person who tended to take that cookie, not only that, but they ate in this kind of impulsive way where their lips were smacking, mouths were open. Crumbs, we took it seven months ago, this crumbs falling on their sweaters. And again, what this tells us is really two things, Shankar, which is power does make us a little bit more self-focused. In this, you're sharing less, you're keeping more for yourself, you're eating the cookie in an impulsive way. But the other thing, I think we shouldn't lose sight of is this can happen to us all, right?
拿了第四块饼干，结果往往是我们当中那个高权力的人倾向于拿那块饼干，不仅如此，他们还以一种冲动的方式吃饼干，嘴唇发出啧啧声，嘴巴张得大大的。碎屑——我们七个月前做的这个实验——碎屑掉在他们的毛衣上。再次说明，这向我们揭示了两件事，尚卡尔，那就是权力确实让我们变得更自我中心。在这种情况下，你分享得更少，为自己保留得更多，你以一种冲动的方式吃饼干。但另一件事，我认为我们不应忽视的是，这可能会发生在我们每个人身上，对吧？
This is just what the mind does when we feel powerful. Because of course, these were just random people who are brought into the lab and you've randomly picked one of them to assign them a feeling of power. Yeah, absolutely. You did mention there were five cookies and three people, so what happened to the fifth cookie? Well, this was where it was really interesting because, you know, the rules of politeness suggest that you really should not be that uncouth person who takes the last cookie off the plate. And so we did pilot testing for the experiment
这只是当我们感到有权势时大脑的反应。因为当然，这些只是被带到实验室的随机人群，而你随机挑选了其中一人并赋予他们权力的感觉。是的，绝对是这样。你确实提到有五个曲奇和三个人，那么第五块曲奇怎么处理了？嗯，这就是有趣的地方，因为你知道，礼貌的规则表明，你真的不应该做那个在盘子里拿最后一块饼干的粗鲁的人。所以我们为实验做了预测试，
and no one would take that fourth cookie. So that's why we added a fifth cookie just to free somebody up to take that second, the fourth cookie. So that's where we added a fifth cookie just to free somebody up to take that second the last cookie. So it's fascinating because of course what you see in these lab experiments is often reflected on much, much bigger stages where you see people in power abusing that power, you know, having affairs, cheating and, you know, falsifying financial returns. At one level, the conventional view, I think, is sort of say these are just people who were bad people who rose to the top. What you're suggesting is actually something more complex and in some ways much sadder,
没有人会去拿第四块饼干。这就是为什么我们加了第五块饼干，好让某人可以放心地去拿第二块、第四块饼干。所以这就是我们加第五块饼干的原因，好让某人可以放心地去拿倒数第二块饼干。所以这很迷人，因为你在这些实验室实验中看到的现象，往往在更大得多的舞台上得到了反映，在那里你会看到掌权者滥用权力，你知道的，有婚外情、作弊以及伪造财务报表。在某种层面上，传统的看法，我认为，可以说是把这归咎于那些登上顶峰的本就是坏人。而你所暗示的实际上是一些更复杂的事情，在某些方面要悲伤得多，
which is that these might not be bad people who rose to the top, but these might be good people who rose to the top and but these might be good people who rose to the top, and power has made them bad. Yeah, I mean, that's such a very compelling and sweeping statement about this Shankar, you know, that does align with how I read this social scientific evidence, which is that you know, there are dozens of experiments where we randomly assign typical people to either positions of power or less power, and you find these patterns where, if I'm just randomly given power, and I feel this sense of sort of expansive euphoria that comes with power and a sense of omnipotence, I speak more rudely, I take resources that are meant
那就是这些人可能不是爬到顶峰的坏人，而是他们可能是爬到顶峰的好人，但权力把他们变坏了。是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常引人注目且全面的陈述，尚卡尔，这确实符合我阅读社会科学证据的方式，也就是说，你知道的，有数十项实验，我们将典型的人随机分配到权力或较低权力的职位上，你会发现这些模式：如果我只是被随机赋予权力，并且我感受到了随权力而来的那种扩张的欣快感和全能感，我说话会更粗鲁，我会拿走本该属于
for somebody else, I'm more likely to flirt inappropriately, I'm more likely to engage in inappropriate sexual behavior. We have studies showing when you make somebody feel powerful. You're more likely to cheat at a game to win 50 bucks. The list goes on. And it really lends credence to Lorde Acton's old observation that I think stands the test of time, which is power corrupts and absolute power corrupts absolutely.
别人的资源，我更有可能不合适地调情，我更有可能从事不当的性行为。我们有研究表明，当你让某人在心理上感到有权势时。你在游戏中作弊以赢得50美元的可能性更大。这样的例子不胜枚举。这确实印证了阿克顿勋爵那句经受住时间考验的名言：权力导致腐败，绝对权力绝对腐败。
You've also found the same thing looking at drivers of various cars. I understand you ran an experiment where you stood outside an intersection and saw who stopped at a stop sign. Yeah. I mean, so I remember one day I was biking to work and I almost got hit by a black Mercedes and the guy, you know, and I was in the riot, I sort of waited and gone through this faraway stop area in California and this guy plowed and almost hit me and he looked at me as if, you know, I was the Hoi Polo and should be sort of taken off the road. And I thought, you know, it'd be really interesting to test these ideas about the impulsive actions that power
你还发现驾驶各种车辆的司机也存在同样的情况。据我了解，你做过一个实验，站在十字路口观察谁在停车标志前停车。是的。我的意思是，我记得有一天我骑自行车上班，差点被一辆黑色奔驰撞了，那家伙，你知道的，我在正确的路权上，我在加州一个较远的停车区等着，这个家伙猛踩油门差点撞到我，他看着我，好像我是，你知道的，我是下层阶级，应该被赶出路面一样。我想，通过观察人们开车来测试权力产生的冲动行为这些想法，会非常有趣。
produces by looking at people drive. So you know what we did in one of the versions of this study is we put a young Berkeley undergraduate at a pedestrian zone right next to the Berkeley campus. The pedestrian zone is a strip that cuts across the road that is the it gives the pedestrian the right of way. You get to cross the road. It's white the pedestrian the right of way. You get across the road. It's white stripes. And then we coded, and we had these Berkeley undergrads kind of hide it in the bushes. Our one student was standing at the pedestrian zone, the other student who was coding was
所以你知道，在这个研究的其中一个版本中，我们在伯克利校园旁边的一个行人专用区安排了一位年轻的伯克利本科生。行人专用区是一条穿过马路的带状区域，它赋予了行人优先通行权。你可以穿过马路。上面有白色的斑马线。然后我们进行编码，让这些伯克利本科生藏在灌木丛里。我们的一名学生站在行人专用区，另一名负责编码的学生则
noting the make of the car, and weather, very simply, did they stop for the pedestrian, which is law, or did they blaze through the pedestrian zone? And 0% of our drivers have poor cars, the Ugo's and Plymouth satellites of the world, drove through the pedestrian zone, 46.2% of our drivers of wealthy cars, you know, the Mercedes and the like drive through the pedestrian zone. 46%? Is this something to do with Berkeley? You know, it's funny. I just got a letter from a guy in Germany who was like, this would not happen in Germany where we really value our Mercedes and BMWs. You know, we've replicated it. It's been replicated in other states.
记录汽车的品牌，以及非常简单的一点：他们是为行人停车（这是法律规定），还是直接从行人专用区呼啸而过？在我们的驾驶员中，0%开廉价车的司机——也就是世界上的雨果（Yugo）和普利茅斯卫星（Plymouth Satellite）汽车——会直接冲过行人专用区；而46.2%开豪车的司机（你知道的，奔驰之类的车）会直接冲过行人专用区。46%？这跟伯克利有关系吗？你知道，这很有趣。我刚刚收到一个德国人的信，他说：在德国绝对不会发生这种事，因为我们真的很重视我们的奔驰和宝马。你知道的，我们已经复制了这项研究。它在其他州也被复制了。
It led people to email me from all manner of context. One of my favorites was a prehistriver email me and said, well, you know, that's Mercedes, but of course prehistrivers abide by the law. So we checked and prehistrivers were actually the worst. So, you know, and this just fits this larger profile that I'm sure your listeners are aware of that there's something about the seductions of power that makes you lose sight of ethics and other people's interests.
它促使来自各种背景的人给我发电子邮件。我最喜欢的其中之一是一位警察给我发邮件说，嗯，你知道，那是奔驰，但警察当然是遵纪守法的。所以我们进行了核实，发现警察其实是最差的。所以，你知道的，这符合这样一个更大的现象——我相信你的听众也知道——权力的诱惑似乎有一种魔力，让你忽视伦理道德以及他人的利益。
You're talking the book about leaders who are able to overcome the paradox of power and we talked earlier about Lincoln and how his rise to power was marked by demonstrations of these positive behaviors, but you also write about how he was able to retain a sense of that kinder gentler, more empathetic self, even as he acquired and wielded great power. Talk about that story and what he did that might be illustrated for the rest of us.
你在书中谈到了那些能够克服权力悖论的领导者，我们之前讨论过林肯，以及他的权力崛起是如何以这些积极行为的展现为标志的，但你也写到了他是如何在获得和行使巨大权力的同时，依然能够保持那种更善良、更温柔、更有同理心的自我意识。请谈谈这个故事，以及他做了什么，这可能会给我们其他人带来启发。
Well, I think that the thing that really is striking about Lincoln's power is, you know, he had a short presidency, but he remained focused on the interests of others. He remained focused on uniting disparate parties and really the greater good, if you will, that he knew that there was this state of the union that he was heading toward. And the way that he did it, you know, is, and it just comes through, for example, Doris Kern's good one's team of rivals, is he just, he kept close to not only the dignity of everybody and treated, you know, the warring sides, if you will, with respect. But he also, and I think this is really important, is that he sort of kept close to the suffering that was involved,
嗯，我认为关于林肯的权力最引人注目的一点是，你知道的，他的总统任期很短，但他始终专注于他人的利益。他始终专注于团结不同的政党，并真正为了更广泛的利益（如果你愿意这样称呼的话），他知道他正在走向一个团结的国家。他做到这一点的方式，你知道的，它确实显现出来了，例如多丽丝·库恩斯·古德温（Doris Kearns Goodwin）的《团队的对手》一书中所写的那样，他不仅与每个人保持亲近并尊重每个人的尊严，以尊重对待交战双方（如果你愿意这样称呼的话）。而且他还——我认为这真的很重要——他与所涉及的痛苦保持着密切的联系，
and what the costs and stakes were, and that was really foundational to his power, and what you see in a lot of the great leaders is this really commitment to the greater good and the concept of respect and the needs of others? You know, Daco, you and I have talked before and as I was reading the book, I remembered something that you had told me in the past, which is you didn't grow up with a lot of power and privilege. And to some extent, you now have some of those things.
以及代价和利害关系是什么，这确实是他权力的基石，你在许多伟大领袖身上看到的是对更广泛利益的真正承诺，以及尊重和他人需求的理念。你知道，达克，你和我以前有过交流，当我在读这本书的时候，我想起了你过去跟我说过的一件事，那就是你成长过程中并没有太多的权力和特权。在某种程度上，你现在拥有了其中一些东西。
And I'm wondering if you can talk about your own journey and you know how your own journey may have changed you and whether you see yourself affected by the very same forces you describe in this book. Yeah, you know, I mean, it's so striking, you know, and it just comes back and bites you and you know, that as I've been lucky enough to get a good education and you know become a professor and be on this show and have a voice. I find I am just as vulnerable to the power paradox as anybody. I find that when I'm feeling powerful, suddenly my scientific acumen is in this sharp. I find when I'm feeling powerful, the way I speak to other people is a little diminished.
我想知道你能否谈谈你自己的心路历程，以及你自己的心路历程是如何改变你的，你是否发现自己也受到了你在书中描述的那些相同力量的影响。是的，你知道的，我的意思是，这太震撼了，你知道，它会回过头来找你麻烦，你知道的，随着我有幸接受了良好的教育，你知道的，成为了一名教授，能够上这个节目并拥有发声的权利。我发现自己和任何人一样，同样容易受到权力悖论的影响。我发现当我感到有权势时，突然间我的科学敏锐度就没有那么敏锐了。我发现当我感到有权势时，我与其他人说话的方式也有所减弱。
Here's one of my favorite examples, and this is not a joke. When I was writing the chapter about the car study that we just described, about people driving fancy cars or feeling powerful, kind of driving in ethical ways, I went to pick up my daughter, who was rock climbing, a bunch of her friends, teenagers piled into the back of the car. I was feeling powerful and writing this chapter and feeling like a good dad. I was captivated by this sense of my own self-worth and I drove off and ran over my daughter's best friends. Flut. Oh my god. You know, so I know and you know, I could have cost a lot of serious damage
这是我最喜欢的例子之一，这不是在开玩笑。当我正在写关于我们刚刚描述的汽车研究的那一章时，关于开豪车的人或感到有权势的人以不道德的方式开车，我去接我的女儿，她当时在玩攀岩，一堆她的朋友，青少年们挤进了车后座。我当时正感到很有权势，正在写这一章，觉得自己是一个好爸爸。我沉浸在自我价值感中，然后我开车出发，碾过了我女儿最好的朋友。砰。噢，天哪。你知道的，所以我知道，而且我本可能造成很多严重的损害
fortunately. I did not, but this is part of the lesson of the book, which is that power is part of every moment of our social lives. We've got to be aware of it. It can lead us to do foolish things, and we should try to do the things that make it a force for good. Dagger Keltener, I want to thank you for talking with me today. It's been great to be with you, Shankar. Dagger Keltener is a psychologist at the University of California,
幸运的是，我没有，但这是这本书的教训的一部分，那就是权力是我们社交生活的每一刻的一部分。我们必须意识到这一点。它会导致我们做一些愚蠢的事情，我们应该努力去做那些让它成为一股善的力量的事情。达克·凯尔特纳，我要感谢你今天与我交谈。很高兴能与你在一起，尚卡尔。达克·凯尔特纳是加州大学的心理学家，
is the author of the Power Paradox, How We Gain, and Lose Influence. of the power paradox, how we gain and lose influence. This episode of the Hidden Brain Podcast was produced by Maggie Pennman, and edited by Tara Boyle. Our staff includes Karam Agar-Kallison, Chris Benderev, Jenny Schmidt, and Renee Clarre. You can find more Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, write a review. It helps others find the show. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. Thanks for listening to Hidden Brain. When you're in the mood for some fun, check out the Ask Me Another podcast for games, trivia and puzzles. It's like trivia night, but much
也是《权力悖论：我们如何获得与失去影响力》的作者。《权力悖论：我们如何获得与失去影响力》。本期《隐藏的大脑》播客由麦琪·彭曼制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括卡拉姆·阿加尔-卡利森（Karam Agar-Kallison）、克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）和雷妮·克莱尔（Renee Klahr）。你可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，并收听你在当地公共广播电台播出的我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请写个评价。这有助于其他人找到这个节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦，这里是 NPR。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。当你心情愉快想找点乐子时，不妨去看看《问我任何事》（Ask Me Another）播客，了解游戏、冷知识和谜题。这就像冷知识之夜，但有趣得多。
funnier. Play along now at npr.org slash podcast and on the npr1 app. one app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在就在 npr.org/podcast 和 npr1 应用上参与互动吧。应用。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。